well take me home country road Logan
lucky normally I wouldn't do a review
for a movie that's been out for more
than a week because I figured nobody
cares about my thoughts and maybe nobody
does but this one's hot because it seems
like nobody's going to it it hasn't done
great at the box office and in addition
to that like most of the reviewers that
I follow on YouTube they haven't tackled
this one either
and that's shame cuz it's pretty good
it's not great I think if you look at
the the Rotten Tomatoes score which I
think is still in the 90s that that
might give you a disproportionate idea
like oh this is a genius film as being
you know it's not genius but you know
what it's good and it's fun and it's an
interesting antidote to a lot of what
you'd expect out of the summer and
certainly what you'd expect out of a
heist film so if you don't know the plot
of Logan lucky it is I mean the simplest
way to put it is it it's a contra 5
version of Ocean's eleven it deals
mainly with Channing Tatum as this guy
who's down on his luck and he has a plan
to steal money basically from from a
NASCAR Speedway and you know he recruits
his team they do the job and then you
get to see all of that play out and so
it is very Ocean's eleven in structure
but the feel is very different it's a
much slower film than you would normally
get in the heist again to me for
comparison to Ocean's eleven which i
think is more than fair because it's
Steven Soderbergh so it's the same
director but Ocean's eleven was very
fast it was very rapid it was very
punchy because those were the characters
rapid-fire dialogue back and forth let's
go this is not that it's like the entire
pace of the story has been slowed down
to match the pace of the characters and
I know I just implied the characters are
slow I don't mean mentally slow I mean
they speak slowly they do things more
deliberately they're not in a rush for
just like as a way of life and the movie
kind of reflects that so it's it's an
interesting way to go about what is
normally a more high-octane kind of
genre which is the witches heist movies
so that's an interesting approach on how
to do it and he gives it its own pretty
unique flavor as far as these things go
because for something that is as slowly
paced as this is normally you think well
it's it's this stupid indulgent artsy
thing and it's not really again it just
suits the characters with these slow
conversations and these slower scenes
but at the same time it's still witty
and funny and the characters are smart
and they are often using the fact that
people they seem to be assuming people
hear them talk and think they're going
to be dumb and they're using that to
their advantage and the cast is really
good Channing Tatum really does a great
job in terms of both portraying sort of
the the mastermind of this thing and
being lovable and he has some great
stuff going on with his daughter there's
some really touching stuff with that
towards the end of the movie Adam driver
as his brother this is the only thing
I've seen Adam driver in outside of Star
Wars so it was interesting for me to see
him do something else as an actor I
think probably for most people the scene
stealer is Daniel Craig as Jo bang who
is kind of doing the sort of jim Varney
kind of convict character it's uh it's
it's a lot of fun it's very obvious that
he's having a lot of fun which is nice
to see because I think you've felt in
his last turn his bond that he didn't
really want to be there for a lot of
that but he's obviously having a lot of
fun here and he wants to be here
I mean he's having a good time and it's
a good supporting cast overall there are
a couple of of weak spots on this one is
Seth MacFarlane who I'll be honest I
like a lot of Seth MacFarlane stuff I
don't know of a ton of it but I
a lot of it and the decision was made
for his character to give to have him
have this English accent which first of
all is not the most convincing accent in
the world but even beyond that I think
it would have played much better into
the feel of the film if he had just used
his normal speaking voice which if you
watch Family Guy's basically just Brian
the dog and I think that sort of because
his his normal speaking voice is like
the epitome of smug college-educated New
England looking down on people kind of
voice and I think that would have been
for what that character was is used that
would have been an even more cathartic
kind of character for him to be playing
than this weird not quite convincing
English accent he does there's also a
whole thing towards the end with Hilary
Swank that I'm not sure I needed to be
there I'm not sure what it added aside
from I guess about 15-20 minutes it
didn't it didn't like kill the movie or
anything I just seemed kind of oddly
obligatory it was a little weird but
overall it is it is a fun kind of
relaxed movie and it's playing with with
a different vibe from most sorts of
movies that you would expect from a high
so if you like heists but you maybe want
to try a different flavor if you like
you know these sorts of more country
sort of characters and and there there
is an interesting mix I mean I'm not
gonna say in there not stupid nub a
couple of them are stupid but some of
them are also really smart so it's not
over playing you know the dumb hillbilly
cliche or anything like that
and it feels respectful to to the
characters and their way of life to be
completely honest I say that as an
outsider looking in I'm not from the
south I don't a family in the south but
that's so take my opinion for what it's
worth probably not much but I I had fun
with this I get I don't want to oversell
it because it is slower pace over your
spectin like oh yeah it's a real romp of
ice it's not quite but it it it is fun
it is funny it's relaxed
it's kind of you know it feels like a
good palate cleanser to the summer so if
you feel like you've got one more summer
ish movie left in you I'd say give it a
watch so Logan lucky I'd ask you if
you'd seen it but the box office would
indicate no no you haven't
so what's your favorite heist movie
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks give a
listen at the council of geeks podcast I
am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast both of those are available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]